Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Surfsharl
VPN, luego os doy más detalles pero antes…
vamos con nuestra historia de hoy.
…
Os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale mirarlo
en Wikipedia ¿Sabríais decirme cuál es
la moneda de El Salvador?
Pues la divisa oficial de El Salvador es el
dólar de Estados Unidos ¡Habéis oído bien!
Desde el año 2001 el dólar estadounidense
es moneda de curso legal en El Salvador.
Sin embargo amigos, a partir del próximo
mes de septiembre, El Salvador tendrá oficialmente
dos monedas: el dólar y, atención, el bitcoin.
Porque sí, amigos, El Salvador acaba de aprobar
el bitcoin como moneda de curso legal ¿Y
esto qué significa exactamente?
Pues que se pueden pagar impuestos en Bitcoin
y todos los comercios están obligados a aceptarlo
como método de pago.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos.
Sobretodo los que seáis fans de las criptodivisas
¡¡¡Viva el Presidente del Salvador, Nayib
Bukele!!!
¡Hagamos las maletas y vayámonos a vivir
a este país!
Es más, si veis este vídeo desde Venezuela
o Argentina, seguramente os suene a música
celestial.
Si hay un problema común en muchos países
de Latinamérica es… la divisa.
Sin embargo, El Salvador es ajeno a estos
problemas ¿Por qué?
Pues, precisamente, porque usan el dólar.
Así que la pregunta es precisamente esa:
¿Qué ha movido a Bukele a declarar el bitcoin
como moneda de curso legal?
¿De verdad se va a convertir El Salvador
en el paraíso de las criptomonedas?
¿O hay algún caballo de Troya en la ley
con la que se pondrá en marcha esta decisión?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas, pero antes…
Antes vamos a hablar de la otra cara de Internet.
La cara de la seguridad en Internet.
Tanto si os gustan las criptos como si queréis
hacer cualquier pago con tarjeta por internet,
teneis que tener mucho cuidado.
Hay un montón de hackers por ahí deseando
hacerse con vuestra información privada y…
robaros.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo podéis protegeros
de los hackers?
Pues una forma muy buena de hacerlo es usando
una VPN para navegar por intenet.
Una VPN como SurfShark VPN.
Surfshark es una VPN fantástica.
No sólo nos protege de hackers, bots de propaganda
y virus.
Además, permite que podamos entrar en cualquier
sitio de Internet sin encontrarnos con esos
mensajes de “esta página está bloqueada
en tu país”.
Vamos, que puedes visitar cualquier sitio
web de forma segura.
Además, Surfshark tiene una herramienta que
se llama CLEANWEB que bloquea todos los popups
de propaganda, por donde se cuelan más bots
y cookies que no queremos tener.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, con una misma
cuenta de Surfshark podrás registrar todos
los dispositivos que quieras ¿Quieres navegar
con seguridad desde tu SmartTV?
¿Desde tu móvil?
¿Desde tu ordenador?
Puedes hacer todo esto con la misma cuenta
de Surfshark.
Y, por supuesto, tenemos un descuento de lujo
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Si usáis el código “POLITIK”, con K
de VisualPolitik, tendréis un 83% por ciento
de descuento más 3 meses extra totalmente
gratuítos.
Tenéis el link en la descripción.
No esperéis más y descargaros ya la aplicación.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
INSERT BITCOIN
¿Cuál es la principal diferencia entre una
criptodivisa y el dinero normal?
El dinero normal, lo que también llamamos,
dinero FIAT, se crea desde los Bancos Centrales.
Por ejemplo, la Reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos o el Banco Central Europeo son quienes
controlan la oferta monetaria de dólares
y euros respectivamente.
Bitcoin y la mayoría de las criptodivisas
son una historia totalmente distinta.
El bitcoin fue creado en 2009 por Satoshi
Nakamoto, un seudónimo que esconde la identidad
real de su creador.
Ni siquiera sabemos quién es.
El bitcoin se basa en la tecnología blockchain
¿Cómo funciona esta tecnología?
Eso es tema para otro vídeo.
Lo importante es que el Bitcoin es una divisa
donde no hacen falta bancos comerciales ni
estados que lo regulen.
Y precísamente, esta es una de las cosas
más importantes del Bitcoin: no está bajo
la supervisión de ningún Estado o Gobierno.
Es decir, no hay nadie que controle la oferta
de Bitcoins.
Teóricamente habrá un número limitado de
bitcoins en la economía mundial: 21 millones
de bitcoins.
Cuando se llegue a esa cifra ya no habrá
más.
¿Y qué ventaja tiene esto?
Pues que impide que llegue el gobernante de
turno y se dedique a manipular la oferta de
dinero.
Así que se supone que esto debería servir
para darle estabilidad a su valor como moneda.
Desde luego esta es la teoría.
Porque la realidad es esta:
Bitcoin azota a los inversores con caídas
y repuntes del 30% en el mismo día
La realidad es que el bitcoin fluctúa más
que la báscula de Russell Crowe ¿Qué significa
esto?
Pues que casi nadie lo usa como método de
pago ¡Pero esperad un momento!
Porque no sólo es que su valor sea especialmente
inestable.
Algo que no se suele mencionar es que bitcoin
también es especialmente lento.
Mirad esta comparación entre la capacidad
de procesar transacciones que ofrece Visa,
la compañía de tarjetas de crédito, y Bitcoin.
Esto significa que en 3 horas Visa tiene la
capacidad de procesar las mismas operaciones
que Bitcoin en un año.
Desde luego Bitcoin puede mejorar, pero la
realidad es esta.
Así que si vives en Estados Unidos o la Unión
Europea, parece mejor seguir funcionando con
los dólares o los euros.
Y ya sé lo que estará pensando mucho ¡Los
de VisualPolitik están totalmente en contra
de las criptodivisas!
¿Verdad?
Pues… no exactamente.
Es más, hay un lugar del mundo donde las
criptodivisas si pueden tener cierto interés.
Hablamos de Latinoamérica.
Hablar de hiperinflación es hablar de Latinoamérica.
Venezuela ha llegado a tener inflaciones de
más del 100.000 por ciento.
Pero no es el único país que ha sufrido
hiperinflación.
Brasil y Nicaragua tuvieron casos de hiperinflación
hace unas pocas décadas ¿Y qué me decís
de Argentina?
Atentos.
La inflación cercana al 50% coloca a Argentina
en un camino en el que antes fracasó
Y diréis ¿Por qué Latinoamérica tiene
tantísima hiperinflación?
La principal razón es que los Bancos Centrales
manipulan la divisa a su antojo.
Dicho de una forma más común: le dan a la
maquinita de imprimir billetes como si no
hubiera mañana.
Esto provoca que sus divisas valgan menos
que los billetes del monopoli.
Así que, la idea de usar una divisa que no
está controlada por ningún gobierno ni ningún
banco central suena como música celestial.
Atentos.
A medida que la economía de Venezuela retrocede,
las criptodivisas llenan los agujeros
Reuters 22-06-2021
Como os podéis imaginar, es lógico que en
Venezuela usen cualquier cosa antes que el
bolívar.
La pregunta es ¿Por qué querrían usar BitCoin
en El Salvador?
A fin de cuentas, en este país usan el dólar
como moneda oficial.
Es decir, no tienen grandes problemas de inflación.
Entonces… ¿Por qué han decidido apostar
tanto por el Bitcoin?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA GRAN IDEA DE BUKELE
El Salvador tiene un presidente millenial.
Nayib Bukele es la nueva rockstar de la política
de Latinoamérica.
Aunque muchos piensan que es un aspirante
a tirano.
De eso hablamos más en profundad en otro
vídeo que os dejo en la descripción.
Pero lo cierto es que, en el programa de Bukele
no decía nada de Bitcoin.
Pero, de repente, en una conferencia sobre
bitcoin celebrada en Miami se emitió este
video del presidente Bukele.
La semana que viene enviaré al Congreso un
proyecto de ley que convertirá a bitcoin
en moneda de curso legal en el salvador.
A corto plazo, esto generará empleos y ayudará
a brindar inclusión financiera a miles de
personas fuera de la economía formal.
Claro, después de esto ya no se hablaba de
otra cosa en El Salvador.
Todo eran dudas.
Porque el único anuncio oficial fue ese vídeo
en inglés emitido en Miami.
Nadie explicaba nada en El Salvador.
Y apenas 3 días después el Gobierno presentó
la ley Bitcoin, que fue aprobada en cuestión
de horas por el Parlamento.
Hablamos de una ley que tiene 16 artículos.
Vamos, que un guión de VisualPolitik ocupa
4 veces más.
En estos 16 artículos no se entra en muchos
detalles pero sí que hay cosas interesantes.
Por ejemplo, que se podrán pagar impuestos
con bitcoin.
Y no, en esto no van a ser pioneros los salvadoreños,
porque desde hace meses el cantón suizo de
Zug acepta el pago de impuestos con Bitcoin
y Ether.
Aún así, no deja de ser llamativo.
Pero si hay un punto polémico en la ley Bitcoin
es su artículo 7.
Mirad.
“Todo agente económico deberá aceptar
bitcoin como forma de pago cuando así le
sea ofrecido por quien adquiere un bien o
servicio.”
Artículo 7 de la Ley Bitcoin (2021)
Según este artículo, parece evidente que
se obligará a los salvadoreños a aceptar
bitcoin, quieran o no.
Y en un primer momento así lo pareció confirmar
el propio presidente Bukele.
Bukele: “Si hay una señora que vende fruta
en el mercado, está obligada a recibir el
pago en bitcóin”
El problema está cuando, una vez aprobada
la ley Bitcoin, dos semanas después te pones
a dar explicaciones.
¿Os acordáis de los hermanos Marx y la parte
contratante de la primera parte?
Bueno, pues Bukele les ha hecho un gran homenaje.
Pues sí, parecería que todos están obligados
a aceptar el bitcoin como forma de pago y
por lo tanto recibir el bitcoin pero no es
así.
Los agentes económicos, es decir, los comercios
están obligados a aceptar bitcoin pero no
a recibirlo
El artículo 8 también es interesante.
Dice que, podrás operar en bitcoin con wallets
privados pero que el Estado proveerá alternativas
que permitan realizar transacciones en bitcoin.
¿Qué quiere decir esto?
Pues ni más ni menos que Bukele ha creado
el wallet del Gobierno para operar con Bitcoins.
Se llamará Chivo.
Y esto ya empieza a chirriar un poco.
Porque una de las premisas de criptomonedas
como Bitcoin es que es algo descentralizado.
Algo fuera del alcance de los Gobiernos.
Eso por no hablar de otro asunto que no inspira
mucha confianza.
Si hay algo que llevó a Bukele a arrasar
en las elecciones es que se presentó ante
la gente como un paladín de la transparencia
y la lucha contra la corrupción.
Un adalid con el que olvidar los escándalos
de los Gobiernos del FMLN.
Sin embargo amigos, lo que rodea al wallet
Chivo recuerda demasiado a las malas prácticas
del pasado.
Bukele imita al FMLN y adjudica proyecto Bitcoin
de forma directa
De forma directa.
Es decir, sin concurso público, ni licitación
ni nada de nada.
Bukele ha adjudicado el desarrollo del wallet
Chivo a dedo a una empresa estadounidense
que se llama Strike.
Pero esperad un momento, porque la Ley Bitcoin
esconde todavía alguna trampa.
Después de lo que vamos a ver será momento
de que los fans del bitcoin respondáis a
la gran pregunta, que es si de verdad os iríais
a El Salvador para poder vivir vuestro día
a día haciendo uso de vuestra criptomoneda
favorita.
Así que, atentos a la pantalla.
LA LETRA PEQUEÑA DE LA LEY BITCOIN
¿A que no sabéis cual es la principal fuente
de ingresos de El Salvador?
Las remesas.
Una cuarta parte de los salvadoreños, unos
2 millones de personas, viven en el extranjero.
La mayor parte en Estados Unidos.
Todos estos salvadoreños envían dinero a
sus familias.
¿De qué cantidades hablamos?
Ni más ni menos que de casi 6.000 millones
de dólares cada año, unas cifras equivalentes
al 20% del PIB de El Salvador.
El país ingresa lo mismo por esta vía que
por sus exportaciones.
Los salvadoreños que han emigrado utilizan
los giros postales para enviar estas cantidades
a sus familias.
Hablamos de empresas como Western Union o
MoneyGram, entre otras.
Por supuesto, estas compañías no lo hacen
gratis y cobran comisiones.
La cuestión, según asegura el presidente
Bukele, es que los ciudadanos salvadoreños
se beneficiarán si utilizan bitcoins en lugar
de dólares para hacer las remesas porque
será más barato.
¿El problema?
Que los datos se empeñan en llevarle la contraria.
Curiosamente, el Salvador tiene una de las
comisiones para remesas más bajas del mundo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, la media en
Latinoamérica es del 5,6%.
En El Salvador es del 2,85%.
Quedaos con este número: 2,85%.
Y diréis ¿Cuánto cuesta cambiar de dólares
a BitCoin?
Pues la empresa que más cajeros de BitCoin
tiene en el país se llama ATHENA.
Esta empresa cobra una comisión del 5%.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué entonces tanto
interés en el bitcoin?
Pues aquí viene una posible explicación:
el Gobierno de El Salvador no tiene ningún
control sobre las remesas.
Ni sabe cuantas llegan ni las puede poner
impuestos.
Sin embargo ¿Y si las remesas llegara en
Bitcoin?
Imaginad que mandamos bitcoins a alguien en
El Salvador que tiene un wallet de Chivo.
Ese wallet es del gobierno.
Dicho de otra forma, podría colocar la comisión
que quisiera.
¡Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando!
¿Y si usamos otro wallet que no sea el del
Gobierno?
Y aquí es donde llega la letra pequeña de
la ley.
Y las cosas no están tan claras.
El Salvador: Fondos para cambiar el bitcóin
a dólar serían insuficientes
Acudamos de nuevo a la Ley Bitcoin.
Su artículo 14 dice que el Estado garantizará,
la convertibilidad automática e instantánea
de bitcoin a dólar… siempre y cuando uses
su Wallet.
Es decir, el Wallet CHIVO ¡Pero esperad un
momento porque hay más!
Aquí llega el ARTÍCULO 9 de la ley ¿Qué
dice ese artículo?
Habla de limitaciones a las alternativas de
conversión automática.
Dicho de otra forma: que el gobierno podría
prohibir usar otro wallet que no fuera el
del Gobierno.
Es cierto, estas limitaciones están por fijar
en un reglamento.
Y diréis ¿Por qué querrían limitar los
wallet que se usan?
Pues veréis: el Gobierno ha creado un fondo
de 150 millones de dólares para garantizar
la conversión de bitcoin a dólar.
El problema es… ¿Qué pasaría si todo
el mundo se lanzara a cambiar de bitcoin a
dólar?
¿Qué pasaría si ese fondo se agotara?
Pues… lo cierto es que nadie lo sabe.
Y Bukele para ocupado con otras cosas.
Nayib Bukele, presidente de El Salvador, se
'pone' ojos láser (en twitter) para apoyar
el Bitcoin
Bukele ha disparado el gasto público sin
subir los impuestos.
El país necesita dólares para pagar su endeudamiento.
Estos dólares le pueden llegar de las remesas
mientras sus ciudadanos reciben bitcoins.
La papeleta para los salvadoreños tampoco
es sencilla.
En resumen: si no usas el wallet del Gobierno
te comerás el riesgo de tener bitcoins porque
ya conocéis su volatilidad.
Así que, de partida, tienes un incentivo
muy gordo para usar el wallet del Gobierno.
Y claro, si usas ese wallet, el Chivo, habrá
que estar atento al reglamento que fije las
limitaciones del wallet.
Porque una vez acabados los dólares del fideicomiso
podría darse una situación de corralito
en la que esté limitado el cambio a dólares.
Dicho de otra forma, que lo único que te
queden son los bitcoins, con los que podrás
operar en El Salvador… pero que no te van
a ser muy útiles fuera del país.
Además, pensad que Bukele tiene entre manos
otro problema urgente que resolver:
El Salvador cerró 2020 con mayor deuda de
su historia
La deuda del país supone ya más del 90%
del PIB.
Dicho de otra forma ¿Por qué no iban a colocar
una tasa para sacar tajada de las remesas?
Eso por no hablar de que los salvadoreños
pagarán impuestos con bitcoins, el fideicomiso
de dólares se va a convertir en bitcoins…
vamos, que de repente el Estado salvadoreño
va a verse en su poder con un montón de bitcoins,
con todo lo que eso implica.
Es que la decisión de Bukele puede convertirse
en un pelotazo si el bitcoin se revaloriza.
Pero puede pasar todo lo contrario y ser una
ruina si el bitcoin se hunde.
En ese caso la gran pregunta es cómo se las
apañará entonces El Salvador para afrontar
su deuda externa.
Mucho me temo que terminaremos hablando de
eso en los próximos meses.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros.
¿Creéis que la decisión de Bukele es un
acierto o demasiado arriesgada?
¿Os gustaría que vuestro país también
convirtiera el bitcoin en moneda de curso
legal?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.